les sept grands pays industrialisés du
monde se tourne vers l'est pour
encourager des la pologne et la hongrie
dans leurs transformations économiques
sommet des peuples pauvres à paris des
personnalités venues de ces pays les
plus déshérités du monde réclame une
remise de la tête et la préservation de
leur environnement meurtre près de nîmes
un jeune fils de harki tué d'un coup de
fusil par un homme qui a pris la fuite
sa famille et ses amis ses caisses pour
le maire du village
madame monsieur bonsoir après les
flonflons du bicentenaire de la
révolution française qui se sont
terminées tard dans la nuit d'hier soir
les chefs les sept chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des pays les plus
industrialisés de l'industrialiser
pardon de la planète sont réunis pour un
sommet d'un peu plus de 48 heures ils
ont tué aujourd'hui une journée de
travail chargée une série de décisions
plus ou moins importantes ont été prises
renouvellement de la condamnation de la
répression en chine et une décision de
lutte accrue contre le terrorisme
l'essentiel du débat étant tout de même
centré autour de la dette d'un certain
nombre de pays en graves difficultés
économiques
on devrait d'ailleurs plutôt dire des
dettes au pluriel car elles ne sont pas
toutes considérés de la même façon selon
qu'elles viennent des pays du tiers
monde ou de l'europe de l'est
de plus il n'ya pas que les états qui
sont concernés mais aussi les banques
qui ont prêté à titre privé le résumé de
cette journée à l'arche de la défense
avec georges bortoli et yves barbe
les sept prennent de la hauteur au 35ème
étage de l'arche dont le marbre de
carrare aide à celles au soleil
la beauté de ce cadre semble affluer sur
l'humeur des participants madame
thatcher ne paraît pas amertume et par
les quelques sifflets qui ont marqué son
passage sur les champs elysées monsieur
bush un sourire même si c'est pour dire
en fait non à la proposition de monsieur
mitterrand d'un sommet nord sud
jacques attali conseiller spécial de
monsieur mitterrand a le sourire de
celui qui a organisé un sommet par comme
les autres et les sept chefs de
délégations ont le sourire des membres
d'un
l'homme très sélect ce club des sept
pays les plus riches du monde + 1 8e
mans pour la communauté qui n'est pas
trop pauvres non plus sur quoi on passe
aux affaires sérieuses les cameramen
représentant 60 et quelques télévisions
payantes été évacués et les six mille
journalistes parmi lesquels le magnat de
la presse britannique robert maxwell
mais une tache de couleur vive attendent
les premières déclarations du sommet
dont une s'arrachent littéralement
lorsque les publier car elle apporte sur
les relations est ouest du nouveau
roland dumas le confirme il y aura une
aide économique accrue des pays
occidentaux à la pologne et à la hongrie
et c'était 2 sera coordonnée par la
commission des communautés européennes
que préside jacques delors en somme la
commission devienne puissance à part
entière comme les grands pays comme
l'italie et la grande bretagne et les
très grands comme les etats-unis la
grande affaire du jour c'est donc comme
bien le dire georges bortoli la mission
donner à la communauté européenne de
coordonner l'aide vers les deux pays de
l'est qui se démocratise et s'engage sur
la voie de la réforme économique la
pologne et la hongrie
une aide que les sept chefs d'état et de
gouvernement voudrait voir s'engager
très rapidement
reste à savoir si elle ne se fera pas au
détriment d'autres pays du sud comme
ceux de l'afrique que la france voudrait
bien voir également prises en compte à
l'arche de la défense philippe sassier
on jubile dans l'entourage de jacques
delors le président de la commission
européenne est donc chargé d'organiser
dans les semaines qui viennent
une réunion où viendront tous ceux qui
sont intéressés par une aide à la
pologne et à la hongrie
une mission qui prolonge en quelque
sorte le traité signé il y a un an entre
la communauté et le marché commun de
l'est le comique
qui compte 390 millions de consommateurs
vous avec lesquels les européens de
l'ouest font moins de commerces qu'avec
la petite suisse les américains soucieux
d'ouvrir les magasins communiste aux
produits made in usa ont accepté un
médiateur européen et tout à l'heure il
ya eu un nouveau coup de théâtre le
président mitterrand a reçu une lettre
de cinq pages sur les problèmes
économiques internationaux signés par
qui est bien par monsieur gorbatchev
décidément au sommet de l'arche pour le
moment les problèmes économiques est
ouest ont soufflé la vedette aux pays du
tiers-monde à la dette du tiers monde il
est vrai que depuis que les américains
voient dans l'union soviétique non plus
l'empiré du mal mais une espèce de
gigantesque assiette au beurre ils sont
davantage intéressés par les
consommateurs de l'est que par les
endettés du sud
c'est vrai maintenant le sommet n'est
pas terminé on va encore parler de
dettes et d'environnement mais tout à
l'heure les mesures financières qui nous
ont été annoncés aux parures aux
observateurs plus technique que real man
politique problèmes concrets de ce
sommet la lutte antidrogue la france
propose une cellule d'action financière
pour lutter contre les arrivées de
drogue dans les différents pays du monde
et également pour lutter contre l'argent
sale de la drogue qui est réinvesti dans
des circuits classiques de l'économie de
monsieur bérégovoy s'explique il y à
aussi mettre en place un certain nombre
de dispositions visant à traquer traquer
l'argent qui résulte de la vente et du
trafic de la drogue
et ainsi que vient de le dire monsieur
védrine
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement se
mettront d'accord sur la constitution
d'un groupe de travail que l'on pourrait
appeler aussi cellule d'action
je dirais pour compléter la pensée des
ministres des finances
et pour bien l'exprimer cellule d'action
financière contre le blanchiment de
l'argent de la drogue et en marge de ce
sommet une querelle querelle franco
britannique qui fait beaucoup parler
principalement d'ailleurs la presse
anglaise en effet depuis le dernier
sommet européen celui là de madrid la
mésentente cordiale s'est installée
entre paris et londres
alimenté par une déclaration de madame
thatcher à la veille du bicentenaire de
la révolution estimant que la france
n'est pas le premier pays des droits de
l'homme et en écho dans une interview à
la télévision britannique est bien le
premier ministre français monsieur
michel rocard accuse madame thatcher de
cruauté sociale en quête de véronique
auger et jean corne longue à partie hier
entre monsieur mitterrand et madame pas
de chair au pied de la pyramide il
fallait calmer la presse conservatrice
britannique qui au même moment à londres
se prépare est attitré les grenouilles
c'est à dire les français attaquent
maggie notre premier ministre
c'est l'objet de vexations on l'a mise
au dernier rang à l'opéra de la bastille
et elle a poireauté 45 minutes après le
défilé polémique sur la forme
polémique sur l'origine des droits de
l'homme et enfin interview de michel
rocard à thiennes alfort une télévision
anglaise interview qui a encore ravivé
la colère des journaux de droit
l'orientation de l'actuel pouvoir
britannique madame thatcher sait fort
bien que je pense cela une cruauté
sociale dont je crains qu'elle ne
détériorent d'abord les relations inter
catégories sociales avant de bretagne
les relations entre régions de la grande
bretagne est peut-être un jour la
qualité même la démocratie politique
mais tous se relativise dès que l'on
passe sous l'arche de la défense
les journalistes anglais du sommet
regard d'un oeil presque attendri ces
bisbilles franco-britannique désormais
coutumière monsieur rocard je ne sais
pas qui c'est dix photographes anglais
vous savez le taux de chômage en
angleterre est tombé à 6%
le vôtre et à 10% madame fait peur en
est fier mais c'est normal que les
socialistes critiques des conservateurs
ces bisbilles son traditionnel et elles
dureront aussi longtemps que nos deux
pays existeront et ça vous plaît oui et
aux français aussi
ce week end à paris il ya deux sommets
qui se suivent et ne se ressemblent pas
forcément
le premier officiel on vient d'en parler
à large de la défense le second à la
salle de la mutualité qui regroupe des
personnalités appartenant à sept pays
parmi les plus pauvres du monde
reportage de martine laroche-joubert et
noël alexandre décor le moins
protocolaire qui soit la mutualité les
sept non pas des chefs d'état et des
syndicalistes et des témoins l'ont
gouvernementaux réunis pour ce premier
sommet des sept pays parmi les plus
pauvres se met miroir de celui qui se
déroule en ce moment à l'arche de la
défense mais un miroir critique
reflétant la volonté de se faire
entendre pour tous les sans voix de la
planète
ils dénoncent la confiscation du pouvoir
par les états les plus riches et
demandes dont le droit à la parole pour
ce qui les concerne directement la
pauvreté la dette
l'armement l'environnement n'ont pas un
contre sommet une déclaration de guerre
mais plutôt à semer complémentaire avec
un objectif le dialogue
à l'issue de cette journée une
déclaration finale lue à l'extérieur de
la mutualité
il souhaite entre autres la remise de la
dette des pays du tiers monde
la révision des règles financières
internationales la création d'un groupe
chargé de dresser le bilan des
précédents sommets des pays riches en ce
moment même ils sont reçus par jacques
attali mais ils ont déjà posé un
principe de base
il refuse toute charité
lorsqu'on évoque la dette des pays
pauvres on aligne des colonnes de
chiffres on comptabilise des centaines
de millions de dollars et cette dette
eh bien il faut savoir que ce sont aussi
des hommes des femmes et des enfants qui
la subissent eux quotidiennement ainsi
au sénégal où se sont rendus nos envoyés
spéciaux gilles rabin et dominique
merlin et bien les habitants sont
touchés de plein fouet leurs conditions
de vie précaires sont devenus à ce point
insupportable qu'il leur faut
aujourd'hui réinventer une forme
d'économie différentes
cette expérience reste encore à l'état
embryonnaire mais elle commence tout de
même à se développer en marge de l'état
sénégalais qui ne remplit plus sa vraie
fonction et la simplification
ces écoliers pourront peut-être
comprendre un jour les mécanismes de la
dette
vas-y savent déjà l'essentiel ils en
sont eux les enfants les premières
gammes
l'an dernier encore tous étaient des
mendiants abandonné à la rue par des
parents incapables de les nourrir au
sénégal hors de la famille passage la
dette paralyse et à la population les
gens se cotisent pour construire des
cons
les gens se cotisent pour assurer un
minimum de deux fentes et les ans coûte
yves pour permettre de sucre yves parce
qu'elle voyait trop d'enfants mendier
une grand-mère à collecter des fonds
privés pour construire le dahra de
manica cette école islamique sans doute
aujourd'hui la plus belle du sénégal
c'est ce que nous voulions mais ça ne
s'arrêtait pas là nous aurions aimé
évidemment étendre l'expérience en faire
profiter davantage d'enfants puisque
finalement nous avons à peine une
centaine d'enfants qui ont fait fuir il
échappe alors qu'il y ait encore des
milliers d'enfants qu'ils prennent et ne
nous restera une école pilote
tout en espérant que ben ça s'étendra
davantage et qu'on pourra pas bénéficier
davantage d'enfants première victime de
la dette l'enfant deuxième victime la
femme à dakar malgré leur travail les
servantes et les lavandières ne mangent
pas tous les jours à leur fin ce foyer
gargotes est devenu leur refuse et aussi
bien sûr celui de ceux qui parviennent
tout juste à survivre le repas coûte 1
francs cfa de francs français
mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel ici on
veut réinventer les vieilles solidarité
africaine que la crise économique et la
dette ont emporté solidarité de misère
solidarité entre femmes et entre
générations dans le quartier arafat de
dakar l'état n'assure plus la protection
maternelle et infantile la pesée des
nourrissons se fait en plein air
l'expérience des matrones bien rassurer
les maires toujours trop jeune elles ont
la plupart du temps leur première enfant
15 ans qu'il est au moins quatre des
naissains mais vous avez le collier
enfin ça dépend toujours de l'âge de
mariage et c'est pas à notre portée de
décider de l'âge de mariage pour aider
bénévolement les voisines de son
quartier
cette jeune femme a suivi des cours de
puériculture pendant deux ans
elle s'appelle caddie ndour par les
français mais pour l'interview l'exigé
de répondre dans sa langue le wolof
caddie ndour à 26 ans les victimes de la
dette n'ont plus accès à la terre ni au
travail ni à l'école ni à la santé parce
qu'elle n'avait pas non plus accès au
crédit bancaire
cent trois femmes du quartier ont créé
leurs propres caisses d'epargne
cette banque sans guichet à financer une
cinquantaine de microentreprises et de
petits métiers elle fait 14 % de
bénéfices la france pose problème mais
le fait de donner l'argent suffit pas il
faut aussi accompagner les gens dans
leur réflexion pour les aider à trouver
des canaux porteurs de
pour preuve d'intérêt et puis c'est de
le soutenir sur le plan humain parce que
dans un quartier populaire
quelques valeurs je pense que très
souvent à force de daval dg chez les
gens finissent à manquer de confiance en
eux mêmes ils ont eu l'idée de récupérer
les vieux tissus pour en faire des
vêtements ils ont créé une mode qui fait
déjà le tour du monde il exporte en
europe et aux états unis
superboy là c'est sûr la fête avec toute
l union des fleurs bernadette la
destruction de la frontière actuellement
il ya un morceau qui est reparti talent
de la mauritanie ont valeur et ça lui va
et la dernière pluie
les espadrilles pour les femmes c'est le
sac pour les en profite point que 38
parce qu'à cause de la bête
l'état principal acteur économique
depuis l'indépendance se désengage
aujourd'hui c'est économie informelle
est en phase de devenir l'économie
réelle du sénégal
le concert est gratuit
ils sont venus des bidonvilles qui
cernent le grand dakar la musique du
groupe c des manies chantent leur misère
et leur révolte eux continuent de subir
en voilà font les appelle l'état loubet
notamment ceux qui vivent autour d'un
feu parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'abri
l'actualité de ce samedi en france ce
sont trois affaires douloureuses trois
jeunes maghrébins assassiné le premier à
dijon dans une bagarre le deuxième à
cluses en haute-savoie tué d'un coup de
couteau à la suite d'une bagarre
également dans ces deux cas les
coupables ont été retrouvés et arrêtés
enfin près de nîmes un fils de harki a
été mortellement blessé par un tireur à
la carabine qui s'est enfui à bord d'une
voiture les amis et la famille de la
victime demande justice et cet après
midi ils ont séquestré le maire de la
commune où a lieu le drame en quête de
nos correspondants à marseille patrice
de l'est et jean françois georges est
retranché dans la mairie armés
déterminés cinq ou six jeunes français
musulmans et le maire ce qu'est ce
serait vers 15 heures la situation se
tend brusquement
depuis le matin les manifestants
réclament sans succès
la présence des autorités le barrage de
la colère une centaine de voitures le
mécontentement qui enfle sentiment
d'exclusion le droit et pour chaque
paire forme manifestation spontanée
d'une minorité mal intégré les
descendants des harkis une minorité
française selon elle trop peu reconnue
envie que dans la crainte que dans la
crainte
j'ai des amis qui ne peut même pas
rentrer dans les boîtes de nuit
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont prisés à
saint laurent les arbres la nuit de
jeudi dernier a dégénéré à issam badda
il ya laissé la vie
une voiture joue au stock-car dans les
rues du village ses passagers un jury
les jeunes sur la place jets de pierres
premiers coups de feu et puis le drame
nous on était en haut du côté de la
mairie tout au bout de cette rue et 11
étaient garés ici vous avez mis le plein
phare sur nous le deuxième coup de feu
il est tombé 5 505 marron foncé à
plaques d'immatriculation étaient
camouflés a partout derrière evans 30 la
provocation ne fait guère de doute dans
cette région très marqué par les
conflits racistes sur place le procureur
négocient depuis 19h mais ce soir la
situation semble assez calme pour ne pas
déraper
oui à l'instant même j'apprends que le
maire de cette petite commune vient
d'être libéré en revanche après ces
meurtres
ces trois meurtres de maghrébins et bien
sosracisme l'association d'harlem désir
en appelle à la création d'une cellule
interministérielle contre le racisme en
france à l'étranger nouvel événement en
union soviétique une grève des mineurs
en sibérie des mineurs qui demande non
seulement une amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail mais qui ont
également des revendications plus
politique il réclame plus d'indépendance
et plus d'efficacité pour leur
entreprise
saisie spectaculaire d'ivoire au kenya
l'une des principales bases du trafic
dans le monde une saisie qui intervient
quelques semaines après que la plupart
des grands pays du monde et décidé
d'interdire toute vente d'ivoire 2015 il
y en a pour trois millions de dollars
soit près de 20 millions de francs à lui
seul ce chiffre explique le pourquoi du
massacre
plus d'un millier d' éléphant a battu
les trafiquants d'ivoire se moque
d'exterminer peu à peu les éléphants
d'afrique
le gouvernement du kenya lui ne sait
plus comment lutter contre ce commerce
illicite en montrant ses images naïrobi
veut alerter l'opinion c'est le massacre
se poursuit il n'y aura plus un seul
éléphant sur le continent africain
d'ici 15 ans mesurer peser chaque
défense et répertorier les experts
peuvent ainsi déterminer l'origine de
l'ivoire comme lors des prises de
haschich ou de cannabis
cette cargaison sera brûlé afin d'éviter
tout commerce de défenses d'éléphants
économie le bon point que nous décernons
ce soir concerne l'actualité puisqu'il
s'agit de la petite entreprise
d'aubusson dans la creuse qui a
construit la table du sommet de l'arche
de la défense table en granit poids 9
tonnes reportage de marc maisonneuve et
bernard connard
à aubusson dans la creuse quand on sait
on ne fait pas tapisserie une fois
révélé le marché d'état concernant les
meubles destinés au sommet des sept
soliton une petite entreprise régionale
s'est battu et l'a emporté les 34
salariés ne construis une table
tellement grande qu'elle dépasse de
l'image c'est un monument
ici dans l'usiné les ouvriers disent
qu'elle fait partie de la commande du
président ce meuble car c'est un meuble
pèse 9 tonnes son diamètre 7 mai devant
sa surface 40 mètres carrés est devenu
un bouleversement complet dans la vie de
lusine il a fallu la fabriquer en deux
mois et demi c'est le premier personnage
de l'état
une eau qui reconnaît bon notre
entreprise on court mais très fier de
cette commande de ce que représente pour
nous beaucoup plus douce qu'européen
même pas seulement pour l'aspect
monétaire même si cela représente 15% du
chiffre d'affaires annuel de
l'entreprise 2 millions de francs le
budget a été dépassée impossible de
maîtriser les coûts exemple il a fallu
travailler des heures durant les vérins
hydrauliques pour respecter les plans de
l'architecte franck hammoutène les
ouvriers ont dû construire un plateau en
bois ils n'ont repris vers le granit
gris et de verre seront équipés de
micros enfin décès lié au goût du le
cuir sur lequel reposent les manches des
participants à ce sommet de trois jours
beaucoup d'argent pour peu de temps
un gâchis d'argent pour qui ce pour
l'entreprise oumarou non forcément un au
nom de sueur ont contribué le français
tu mens aujourd'hui la table étant de
l'arche de la défense à paris
mais ensuite servi raté une autre fois
justement suite du sommet des sept
grands pays industrialisés de l'arche de
la défense les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement quitter cette table de 9
tonnes et sont repartis vers la pyramide
du louvre où ils débattent en ce moment
même des problèmes de l'environnement
nous retrouvons au louvre bernard
pradines au bernard et cette discussion
daniel est importante car c'est la
première fois que l'on parle de
l'environnement de façon globale les
dirigeants et nomma notamment ceux des
sept pays industrialisés ont bien pris
conscience qu'il y à une menace réelle
contre l'humanité il ne s'agit plus
simplement de parler de pollution à
propos des forêts ou de l'eau ni même de
la fameuse couche d'ozone
il s'agit d'aborder les problèmes liés à
la défense de l'environnement d'une
façon beaucoup plus générale les sept
réunis autour d'une table de travail à
quelques mètres de l'entrée de la
pyramide ne vont pas prendre des mesures
techniques évidemment mais une impulsion
politique pourrait naître de cette
conversation informelle et ce serait
alors la mort de mesures financières
concrètes approprié qui serait décidée
plus tard monsieur mitterrand pour
l'instant fait visiter à ses hôtes les
sous sols du louvre rénover les salles
médiévales mise à jour par les travaux
archéologiques avant de dîner toujours à
sept autour d'une petite table dressée
tout à côté de la salle de réunion merci
bernard et prolonge ont maintenant un
instant encore les flonflons et les
lumières du bicentenaire de la
révolution française et du défilé de la
marseillaise hier soir sur les champs
elysées un défilé suivi par près d'un
million de spectateurs sur place et 600
millions de téléspectateurs devant leur
écran
l'événement en côté pile c'est à dire
officiel côté face dans la foule
reportage daniel poirier et bruno
girodon
les champs-elysées pris d'assaut ils
sont un million peut être plus pour
apercevoir quelque chose de la parade
tous les moyens sont bons
magnifique on peut rien voir cette appli
ci a largement oui
pris de malaise ou blessés faire des
pétards on les évacue dans le gave au
bout de la nuit les pompiers les
policiers peuvent souffler rien de grave
à signaler
rien à faire pas question que ça
s'arrête et c'est la foule elle-même
envahissant les champs-elysées qui
termine la parade
les organisateurs de ces festivités du
14 juillet ont été félicités par le
gouvernement une note discordante
toutefois celle du front national qui
estime par la voix de bruno mégret son
secrétaire général que la marseillaise
tel qu'on nous l'a présenté hier soir
était le reflet de la société
cosmopolite voulue par les socialistes
et qui ne correspond pas forcément à
l'état d'esprit des français moins
polémique la manière dont une famille de
la noblesse française a vécu ces
événements du 14 juillet 1789 dans une
demeure de normandie qui garde encore
intacts tous ces souvenirs deux cents
ans plus tard reportage de marie josée
le pica et 10 dinars
il a fait très beau aussi l'été 1789 en
normandie
le manoir de lillers les propriétaires
actuels les mérites bellegarde ont
ouvert au public appartenait déjà à leur
famille sur le plan dressé à l'époque on
situe déjà les allées du tilleul le four
à pain qui sert mais pour tout le
village
le puits le bûcher
le petit génie a disparu le pigeonnier
était là à l'emplacement de sétif en
limite entre la seigneurie et le domaine
agricole
il a été rasée à la révolution car
c'était un signe de privilèges mais
jusqu'en 1900 on voyait encore ses
fondations au sol avant qu'on ne fasse
les travaux d'aménagement du parc par le
chemin du roy les nouvelles des
premières émeutes arrive trois ans plus
tôt c'est un mairie de villers et
cheveux à rouen qui a remis les clés de
la ville à louis saez comment cette
famille en vue va-t-elle vivre la
révolution acquis aux idées nouvelles
comme beaucoup de noble de province
michel louis mairie participe à la
rédaction des cahiers de doléances de sa
commune sa femme il y passe ses années
dans le manoir
ils cachent les tapisseries dans la
chapelle et les immobiles elles y
resteront plus de 100 ans
mais la loi c'est aussi des seigneurs de
guilers de simples citoyens
à ce moment là les mairies ont abandonné
les noms des signaux rick les aviez
actes et qu'ils avaient acquis que ce
soit celle de villers où celle de
bellegarde et c'est ainsi que pendant
100 ans
nous sommes redevenus les mairies comme
l'oncle blondel marchand et armateurs à
rouen qui avait acquis la seigneurie en
1766 les mairies d'aujourd'hui habite
toujours villers en juillet 1989 des
fenêtres du manoir il voit remontant la
seine les grands bateaux à voile de la
liberté et bien 180 ans plus tard sans
transition car je n'en trouve pas le 15
juillet 1969
le compte à rebours était lancé pour la
fusée américaine saturn 5 qui allait
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité emmener des hommes sur la
lune à 13h dans notre émission spéciale
et chaque soir dans notre journal
jusqu'au 21 juillet jour où l'homme posa
le pied sur la lune
nous avons et nous allons raconter une
nouvelle fois cette aventure patrick
estel
15 juillet 1969
la dernière nuit avant le grand départ
sur le pas de tir de cap canaveral
saturn 5
l'engin le plus puissant jamais élaborée
par l'homme des centaines de techniciens
finissent la préparation ultime contrôle
remplissage des réservoirs 2200 tonnes
de carburant rien que pour le premier
étage la ceinture de 5 d'apollo 11 doit
permettre d'envoyer trois astronautes et
45 tonnes en orbite lunaire
michael collins neil armstrong et buzz
aldrin
les trois hommes savent qu'ils sont là
pour tenir le serment pris par john
kennedy en 1961 envoyé un américain sur
la lune et le ramener sain et sauf avant
la fin mai mais c'est un pari gagné
durant ce mois de juillet 1969 suite au
prochain numéro le sport maintenant
grand prix d'angleterre de formule un
départ classique demain sur le circuit
de silverstone sénat devant prost
alexandre delpérier à ayrton senna
réalisant le meilleur temps des essais
obtient aujourd'hui la trente cinquième
pole position de sa carrière et la
sixième de la saison
pourtant chez mc laren 24 heures avant
départ du grand prix on est inquiet les
monoplaces de prost et senna présentent
des problèmes de boîte de vitesses
mais ces problèmes n'ont à rien altérer
les performances de leurs voitures pour
les essais et senna partira donc en
première ligne puisqu'il devance alain
prost de 16 centièmes en deuxième ligne
se trouveront les deux ferrari de
mansell est derrière à noter que ces
quatre voitures se tiennent à moins
d'une seconde
les williams renault de patrese et
boutsen sont elles respectivement 5e et
7e
quant au français philippe adieu aux
signes le 12e temps juste devant eric
bernard jean alesi quatrième au grand
prix de france et lui 22e chez ligier
olivier brouillard partira 24e
rené arnoux lui n'a pu se qualifier
alors les faibles écarts qui existent
entre les voitures de tête promettent
une course très ouverte à près de 250 km
heure de moyenne
et on enchaîne avec le tour de france 2e
victoire d'étape pour le landais nijdam
aujourd'hui à gap du toit au sprint
devant le français pascal poisson et le
peloton qui se trouvait juste tout juste
derrière au classement général pas de
changement le français laurent fillon
conserve son maillot jaune de leader
autre course n'ont pas de roues celle là
mais à quatre pattes
il s'agissait du tiercé qui s'est couru
cet après midi à evry pour gagner il
fallait jouer le 5 le 8 et le 4 pour
gagner un peu plus de 2300 francs pour
ce qui concerne le quarté ajouté donc le
numéro 10 et vous gagnez un peu plus de
dix mille francs les pronostics
maintenant de pierrette brès pour demain
le tiercé secours à maisons-laffitte je
vous laisse lire ses pronostics et noter
principalement les numéros 15 3 16 de 9
13 8 14
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après les prévisions météo avec
josé blanc lapierre et puis aux
alentours de 22h50 3 c'est-à-dire aux
alentours de 23h plus exactement et bien
et nous retrouverons jean-claude allanic
pour les toutes dernières informations
de ce samedi vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne et je
vous dis à demain 13h au soir